you
welcome to the City Hall and
congratulations professor Higgs thank
you how was this ceremony wait wait it
was it went extremely smoothly we had a
rehearsal this morning as you as you
know so everybody knew what to do want
me what to do I must ask you which was
the happiest moment was it when you
receive the prize and when you turn that
they had found the particle huh well I
think it was probably when we show an
announcement came in July last last year
after that I think it came as no
surprise that i received a Nobel Prize
it before a year some of my colleagues
thought I was going to give it the same
here but I said that it's prematurity so
which was noted which it was no surprise
when I got the music in October this
year no we weren't surprised either and
there's much talk about the beauty in
maths do you agree well some kind of
mass is more beautiful than other times
in life it in isolation I nation very
ugly mathematics which is ugly and which
is beautiful well when I was a student I
had course in numerical mathematics
which was supposed to help me too
you know understand measurements that I
made another loyalty and not just seem
to be as a set of rules what we're doing
things it wasn't always a coherent angle
my brother too ok but the beautiful one
what's that beautiful map
I think the
a lot of geometry is what I'd call
beautiful and with the mathematics that
I use most is the mathematics for group
theory which is the mathematics of
symmetry and unless I think it's a
really beautiful something do you think
it's comparable to the dude oh well
written books or music yes yes it can be
about them I mean I it's difficult to
draw a close analogy because the English
wait works is different from a good
before music and I I hear that you like
works very much and what type of books
to prefer well it's just in time and I'm
trying to catch up with a vast
collection of unread Knowles as I've
accumulated over the years mmm i think
is in reading and we're not gonna but
I'm not distracted by prizes of red
panda tea I said I'm 50 years ago when
many people doubted that this particle
was a good idea did you ever think I
quit that I there must be something else
to dive into oh no I isip I thought when
when the work was done in 1964 that it
was going to be important in
particle physics but I didn't find the
right place to use it enough I noted
Francois Allaire / / / arch and it was
other people who showed what was the
right context were using it but I'm very
glad that you didn't quit many many many
in warm congratulations to the price and
enjoy the evening evacuate thank you